but it is quite clear that the
prorogation is not a proceeding in
Parliament it takes place in the House
of Lords chamber in the presence of
members of both houses but it is not
their decision it is something which has
been imposed upon them from outside it
is not something on which members can
speak or vote it is not the core or
essential business of Parliament which
the Bill of Rights protects quite the
reverse it brings that core or essential
business to an end this Court has
already concluded that the Prime
Minister's advice to Her Majesty was
unlawful void and of no effect this
means that the order in Council to which
it led was also unlawful void and of no
effect and should be quashed this means
that when the Royal Commissioners walked
into the House of Lords it was as if
they had walked in with a blank sheet of
paper
the prorogation was also void and of no
effect Parliament has not been probed
this is the unanimous judgment of all
eleven justices it is for Parliament and
in particular the speaker and the Lord
speaker to decide what to do next
unless there is some parliamentary rule
of which we are unaware they can take
immediate steps to enable each house to
meet as soon as possible it is not clear
to us that any step is needed from the
Prime Minister but if it is the court is
pleased that his counsel have told the
court that he will take all necessary
steps to comply with the terms of any
declaration made by this Court